Speaker 1: Let's move on now to our next kind of
wacky video of the day. A woman, a spoke before
the Greenville, South Carolina school
board, I believe it was last night. And she,
as far as she's concerned, blew the whistle,
saying the CDC has a plot to shut schools down.
That's really what's behind school and educational
suggestions from the CDC. The CDC wants to shut
schools down and turn them into Third Reich Nazi
style concentration camps where children will be
taken from their parents and presumably subjected
to experiments or who the hell knows what. Now,
what you're going to see, there's a there's a
bunch of interesting things to look at in this
clip. But one of the things you're going to notice
is that this woman can barely even articulate
what the conspiracy is. This is really common
with these people. They get fully sucked into
something. They completely believe it. They don't
even understand that they can. You say explain it
to me. That's I would want to know if the CDC
is doing that. I would want to know and they
can barely explain it. I remember when I was on,
I went to Los Angeles and I was on the Jesse Lee
Peterson show. I went to his studio and he started
going on about socialism and communism. And he was
so confused that I even said to him, Jesse,
you don't even understand your own conspiracy
theories. You don't even understand your own
talking points. That's exactly what's going
on here. So let's take a look at this. And we
should be asking so many questions here, including
why did you wait to blow the whistle on this at
a school board meeting? Why not report it to the
police or to actual authorities who, of course,
would say this is crazy? Ma'am, let's listen.
Speaker 6: The CDC is
Speaker 1: considered
and by the way, I know the audio is skewed to
to one channel. It's just the source audio.
Speaker 6: It's called the shooting
approach for nineteen minutes. The playing.
To shut down schools and to use them as gyms
Speaker 1: so you can tell she's so tentative
and she's reading from an article apparently
posted to get her get TTR, which is like
another one of these failed right wing
social media networks of some kind.
She's she barely understands what she's reading
Speaker 6: to physically isolate men,
women and children. Now, we
know that concentration camps
were something that the Nazis did, OK, but it can
come here at any moment and we need to be aware
that they can call it something other than a
concentration camp. Hmm. Concentration camp can
be disguised as something like a green zone.
Speaker 1:
And so now she's going through the she's so
confused she doesn't know what she's saying. It
makes no sense even to her. But she believes that
Speaker 6: the plan is to take
the plan, talks about the loss of freedoms
and personal interactions that talks about
taking children away from their parents,
families away from each other and separating
separating everyone by genders. My question
is, will the school board comply to the CDC
shooting approach, aka concentration
camps now being renamed as green zones?
And if you if you want a copy, I'll be more than
happy to give you one to look into to do your own
research on, to see what you think about it.
Speaker 1: It's so funny, because if there was
really a plot by one of the premier public health
organizations of the United States to turn schools
into concentration camps, why would we leave it
up to the Greenville School Board to look into
just find some articles? We would be reporting
this to every law enforcement agency. We know
the it's the absurdity of this is the plot. Would
you look into it? School board, please? And let's
just get to a few more minutes. Maybe the most
disturbing part is the people who clap at the end.
Speaker 6: It is everyone's
personal rights. But you think it is
close. You can always give us freedoms, lulls,
but they can always take away our freedoms to
end this right here, plus possibly
take away everyone's freedom
and their families from each other. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Yes. So then the clapping starts.
I think actually the clapping at the end may
be the scariest part. She doesn't understand
what she's reading. This is like I remember some I
admit sometimes in school when I was in elementary
school, middle school, high school, I hadn't read
the book, but I had to give a book report. And so
I would have printed notes that I didn't really
understand because I didn't actually read the book
this. And it's like I'm painfully looking through
and trying to put together some kind of coherent
book report about oral book report based on a book
I haven't read. That's the vibe that I'm getting
here. And the people applauding at the end is, of
course, very scary. She's reading an article that
she found on the Internet. And I don't know,
you know, some people wrote to me, they said,
David, is this person being paid? I don't know
who would pay her. You know, you think if you
were paying someone to do this stuff, they would
be more coherent? The speeches at the meetings,
there's fights taking place at school board
meetings over masks and different things. There's
all sorts of different levels to this. But I don't
understand where these people come from, quite
frankly. And maybe maybe she's been injecting
bleach. And this is one of the side effects.
Maybe she's been bathing in ivermectin paste and
this is one of the side effects, I don't know.
But this is extraordinarily disturbing stuff.
And again, the fact that anybody would think
this woman uncovered the plot. Wow, how did
she do? It must have been that research that
she did that that's even plausible to the
people in the room. It's a really sad state
of affairs. And unfortunately for South
Carolina, South Carolina has been the hub
of a lot of weaponized pandemic disinformation
this entire time. Fortunately for South Carolina,
their health care system is not as bad as
Mississippi and Alabama. The educational system
is not as bad as Mississippi and Alabama. There
are other infrastructure is not quite as bad. So
they've lucked out. Even though South Carolina
has a wealth of weaponized disinformation,
their infrastructure is just slightly
better than some of the states that are
forty nine, 48 fiftieth that
their covered numbers are not
quite as bad as some of those other states. It's
truly remarkable. We'll be back right after this.